[Musique]
java card et on est au stade olympique
où vous venez d'enregistrer une
prestation pour un concert qui va être
diffusée sur le web le 1er juillet pour
la fête du canada
comment vous avez trouvé votre
expérience j'ai vraiment trouvé ça super
impressionnant parce que évidemment on
est dans un lieu grandiose est énorme
mais il y avait vraiment une dualité
avec le fait que la perfo était tout
intime on est on est juste trois dans le
bain avec mes deux musiciens et donc il
y avait un truc très très intime qui
venait un peu justement jouer avec avec
la grandeur de l'espace puis ça vraiment
un créer un moment super impressionnant
pour nous on était très content d'être à
peu près tout le monde s'entend pour
dire que charlotte cardin est une bête
de scène comme à approchez-vous la scène
bella va merci pour le compliment mais
j'ai ça s'est vraiment développée en
tout cas moment mon confort sur scène où
mon fils je vous l'assuré vraiment pas
encore 100% et le pas ce qui est bon
j'ai encore le trac avant de rentrer sur
scène sommet mais ça s'est vraiment
développée en faisant des choses prend
c'est quand même très au sérieux que ce
soit une petite paire faux ou une grosse
ou une grande perf outre ce jeu j'essaie
de garder une hygiène de vie qui est qui
et qui est structuré et donc il ya
vraiment une
une hygiène à ce niveau là qui est de je
prends des cours de change on prend pas
autant que je devrais d'ailleurs le sma
pro deschamps m'écoutait drake mais je
prends des cours de chant encore j'en ai
pris pendant dix ans et puis j'ai arrêté
plusieurs commencer et puis quand on est
en tournée c'est autre chose encore
parce que quand on a beaucoup de choses
suite j'ai pas un corps qui est très
très très bon pour garder de l'énergie
alors il faut que je me repose au max
les bonbonnes pour en témoigner je suis
en train de dormir je fais attention à
ce que parce que je mange on fait peu
trop la fête aussi on a quelques jours
de congés ballon peut se permettre de
mes cheveux je fais vraiment très
attention parce que je pense aux séries
je suis tombé sur internet sur le mini
film charlotte cardin étaient 2010
d'environ 7 minutes où vous tentez d'en
dévoiler un peu sur votre routine de
travail
qu'est-ce que vous avez justement voulu
montrer à votre public mais en fait
c'était c'est un film super 8 que ma
soeur camille réaliser c'est elle qui
m'a prochaine dans ce serait l'fun de
montrer une partie de ta vie qu'on n'a
pas encore vu c'est vrai que je reste
assez privé sur certaines choses puis
elle m'a dit je pourrais venir chez toi
film est un peu ta préparation avant son
spectacle au festival de jazz qui était
un spectacle l'année passée qui est
vraiment le spectacle le plus incroyable
qu'on n'ait jamais fait penser beaucoup
beaucoup préparé pour ce show là
en fait j'avais j'avais envie juste de
montrer une partie de moi que les gens
avaient peut-être pas encore vu que
justement comment moi je me prépare pour
un show comme ça commence et de défaire
des pratiques parce que évidemment des
fois qu'on est sur scène mais moi quand
je vois des artistes que ça a l'air
tellement facile des fois il fut blessé
mais j'ai vraiment beaucoup de
préparation derrière ça j'avais le goût
de montrer un petit poucet au public
vous avez écrit de magnifiques chansons
en anglais et en français
vous avez déjà dit que pour vous
l'écriture est une façon de gérer ce qui
m'angoisse ce qui me dérange ouais en
2020 qu'est-ce qui vous angoisse et
qu'est-ce qui vous dire offrir beaucoup
de choses qui me dérangent en 2020 et
qui m'angoisse ebel justement on est en
plein dedans mais mais tout le mouvement
blake lively marquis et puis il ya
quelque chose d évidemment très très
positif dans le fait que finalement les
gens bougent à ce niveau là les gens
prennent conscience de leur juste de
commencer et se positionne par rapport à
ça puis de ce qu'ils peuvent faire pour
aider ces inégalités raciales qui qui
existent et qui sont partout autour de
nous en ce moment c'est vraiment je suis
en plein là d'enppi en tant qu' en tant
que femme blanche qui a grandi dans un
milieu très privilégiée je sais que j'ai
beaucoup de choses j'ai beaucoup de
d'instruction personnel à faire
là-dessus alors je regarde des
documentaires je regarde je mets jeu
mais depuis je m'informe que ça m'aide
aussi à cerner certaines erreurs ou
certain angle mort que j'ai par rapport
à ces inégalités raciales up je pense
que c'est vraiment un travail que tout
le monde et toutes nationalités tout
oui tous milieux différents devraient
faire s'informer en ce moment mais c'est
tellement important qu'on le fasse parce
que parce que l'égalité raciale n'existe
pas dans notre société
et voilà ça mais je m'emporte même en en
parlant mais mais c'est sans ce moment
qui me qui m'habite énormément ils sont
nombreux à attendre votre premier album
complet le point mini album complet
allez-vous vous
là on est une date finalement en date
mais on ne peut pas encore là dire mais
c'est quand même assez bientôt on peut
pas mais c'est comme ça cet automne tête
charlotte corday merci merci beaucoup
[Musique]